[Music]  this month we're reading the Curious  Incident of the dog in the night-time  this is a heartwarming and heartbreaking  read so you have to be prepared for both  it's the story of a young boy and he has  behavioral difficulties but he's also a  genius at mathematics so that  combination makes for very interesting  reading particularly as the author has  decided to use first-person narrative in  the opening of the book we dive  immediately into the skin of the  protagonist he witnesses the death of  the dogs it's quite violent in a very  objective way we understand that this is  this boy is perhaps doesn't think like  everyone else this book was very unique  because it was originally marketed for  both adults and children I would say  it's for intermediate learners of  English  [Music]